[Music]
sometimes you get angry at people and
you think i want to you know
why is it our current physics theories
can't account for all of the richness
that we see in life the easier things
have been done there is definitely life
out there so why haven't we found it it
may be one of the most transformational
results of the 21st century i don't
think that biological sex is an illusion
but i do think that our binary
conceptualization of sex is an illusion
[Music]
i'm a scientist i'm a molecular
biologist and i study genes so i can't
honestly say that genes don't matter
because i'm afraid they do matter um but
what i understand of the question you
know nature versus nurture i think is is
more
what do we what do i do as a human being
what do i do as a user with information
about this sort of information i think
that's actually what the question is and
not to completely derail the debate
but um
so you know um
i could i could now rattle off
information about you know we know
increasingly certain genes that are
incredibly important for determining
maternal behavior at least in mice for
example if you carry a mutation in this
particular gene and you're a mouse you
won't look after your pups
you know those kinds of studies
obviously do exist they they are
published they i trust them as a
scientist i look at them with the
critical eye but but that's sort of a
scientist's endeavor right
what then happens is these studies get
published and
everybody else including myself as a
human being who doesn't actually specify
and who doesn't specialize in this stuff
reads it and goes what does that mean
for me as a potential mother in the
future what does that mean what does it
mean right
um
and i think i think that's what the
debate's about basically what what you
know i it's undeniable that genes and
your genome
is the basis of who you are as a person
it's undeniable because you start off as
a single cell that is just instructed
with that information that is the basic
starting point of your life it is what
determines how you grow what shape you
are and all the rest of those things
however
we all do many things in our lives that
that aren't necessarily written in our
genes right
i don't know about you guys i don't feel
particularly comfortable in this blazer
right now but i'm wearing it because
it's socially determined that i should
be doing something like that right
you know
sometimes you get angry at people and
you think i wanna you know
but we have society that tells us things
like don't hit people that you don't
like because it's not okay
so we all learn to do things that we we
would you know arguably be going against
our predetermined genetic nature right
so the real question actually i think
that we're faced with at the moment is
um at this in this era of increasing
knowledge and people like myself and and
others on this panel spewing out more
and more facts as it were data about who
we are and what our genes say we are is
actually what do you want to do with
that information about yourself what
kind of person do you want to choose to
be in light of this information
[Music]
people are discussing could we use
crispr gene editing to give coral
different kinds of genetic sequences
that make them resilient to warming sea
temperatures
could we use crispr gene editing
to suppress the emerald ash borer by
introducing sterility into that
population in north america and saving
the ash tree can we use crispr gene
editing to remove invasive species like
the mosquitoes in hawaii that are
spreading avian malaria to threaten bird
species the other places this being
explored is within the public health
space so there's discussions around can
we use crispr gene editing to suppress
the malaria species the malaria carrying
species of mosquito
ideas around using it to remove species
of mosquitoes that carry dengue fever
zika fever chikungunya so this is some
big these are really big ideas and it's
and it's not
it's not fully theoretical anymore i
think that's important that we all
understand sort of the status of where
this is some of this is still kind of at
the very early stages the coral projects
for example are still very kind of in
the idea stage and proof of concept is
it even possible
but we already have for example
mosquitoes that have been genetically
engineered using ways that predate
crispr by a company called oxytec which
has been releasing these mosquitoes in
brazil the cayman islands panama
parts of southeast asia to try and
suppress that population of mosquitoes
and then hopefully suppress dengue
transmission
there's been an american chestnut tree
that has been genetically engineered in
the u.s american chestnuts went
functionally extinct in the u.s about
around the turn of the 19th century and
so there's been ideas about creating
these genetically engineered trees that
would be resilient to an invasive blight
that killed them all off and these are
already in regulatory approval process
trying to release them to be able to
reproduce and spread in the wild and re
and re-regrow just nest forests
and the one that i want everyone to also
be aware of is this project that's
funded by the gates foundation this is a
initiative called target malaria
and they are using crispr gene editing
to create a spe a line of mosquitoes
that when released into the wild would
suppress the mosquito population that
carries malaria and hoping to save human
life and they do this because not only
does crispr allow you to make really
easy gene edits
in any living thing it's also allowed
for the production of what's called a
crispr based gene drive because if you
think about it if anyone remembers their
natural bio their biology training from
way back when things work through
natural selection right so if you're
going to release a mosquito that has
some gene on it that you want to push
through a species population
it's going to go mate with a wild
mosquito there's going to be only 50
inheritance of those genes and
eventually through natural selection
it's quite likely that mosquito would
get pushed out of the population and you
wouldn't really change anything
what a gene drive does is this gene dry
mosquito not only expresses the gene
edit that you want so say it's to push
sterility through this mosquito
population to suppress the population
it also expresses all the tools the
crispr
so the cas9 the garden iron rna the
stuff that we talked about on that
previous slide so that it makes those
very same edits in the wild gene that it
inherits
from from its wild parent so this gene
drive mosquito is going to mate with the
wild
wild parent the child it inherits the
gene edited gene from the gene dry
parents as well as the crispr to then
edit the same gene in the wild parent
and through that you get 100 of
inheritance of a gene and over time
every single mosquito in a population
will have that gene edit that you
require and this is the game changer
this is what's both exciting because it
means you can transform populations of
of species if you're trying to try and
create a solution for something it's
also what's incredibly frightening
you can completely alter a natural wild
species by releasing just a few of these
gene drive mosquitoes
[Music]
i don't think that biological sex is an
illusion but i do think that our binary
conceptualization of sex is an illusion
and the long answer is that this is a
tricky question because we use
biological sex for at least two
different meanings we use biological sex
to describe the divisions of humans into
sex categories male and female according
to the form of their genitalia by
imposing a binary division on on the
form of the genitalia we ignore or we
mistreat individuals that do not fit
into one of these categories so whereas
most humans or the most of humans
genitalia
do fit into the categories because they
have only male typical organs or only
female typical organs some humans don't
now the other meaning that we use
biological sex is to relate to all the
genes and hormones that are involved in
the formation of the genitalia and they
of course exist these genes and hormones
but the binary framework framework
misleads us to believe that these genes
and hormones are arranged into distinct
sets what one appearing in males and the
other appearing with females and this is
simply not true so except from a few
genes on the y chromosomes
all humans show all the genes and the
hormones that are involved in the
formation of the genitalia and they
these genes and hormones especially the
hormones are highly dynamic highly
reactive highly overlapping between
humans and they
clearly do not come into distinct form
like the genitalia do
now these genes and hormones affect not
just genitalia but also other systems
and one of them is the brain and again
the the binary framework misleads us to
believe that sex effects on the on the
brain add up consistently within
individuals as sex effects on the
genitalia often does
to create distinct male brain and female
brains and this again is not true
because sex effects on the brain
usually mix up so each one of us has
features in the brain that are more
common in males and others that are more
common in females so those sex affects
the brain and although there are group
level differences between the brains of
men and women they do not add up to
create male brains and female brains but
rather mosaic brains
[Music]
20 or maybe 30 years ago there was a
survey in britain of churchgoers
they were asked the question would you
or your faith be disturbed if life in
outer space was discovered
and the answers were remarkably
consistent
and remarkably interesting
the answer was no i would not be but
i'd be worried about other members of my
congregation
so i i think this isn't actually the
issue it's sometimes built up to be
i think if and when we do find life
elsewhere
i think people will take it in their
stride it's likely to be at a
considerable distance and contact would
be minimal so we're not about to be
invaded or anything like that
the scene is also changing very fast
as of about now we know of about 40
sorry 4 000 stars that have planets
around them and that number is doubling
every two years
so the number of known exoplanets is
growing very very fast
at the moment that 4000 that's about the
same as the number of stars we can see
in the night sky with the naked eye
unless you live in a city center
so the next time you see a nice starry
sky say to yourself there's as many
planets up there as there are stars
we've
got some criteria i think about what's
desirable
it's helpful to have a large moon
stabilizes the spin axis
it's helpful to have a magnetic field to
screen out particles from a flaring sun
you want a sun that doesn't flare too
much and certainly doesn't explode or
anything like that
you want to be well away from any
massive black hole in the center of the
galaxy
well away from any star that would
explode
and a circular planetary orbit is
helpful
but even with those criteria there are
zillions of possible sites in the
universe
so i think patience is called for in
this game
so yeah we've got all these exoplanets
but only a fraction of them are going to
be suitable we think for a carbon-based
life
in some cases the star will be too
hostile um too much
sort of cosmic rays and things like that
from the star that would break up the
relatively fragile molecules we need to
make life um sometimes the planets are
too close or too far away even if the
star is quiet
steady
so there's a lot of factors you have to
weigh in in doing these sums
but nonetheless we are
our reach is gradually extending with
more and more telescopes so we're
sampling more of the universe that's
undoubtedly true
and particularly with all the work done
to discover exoplanets it's um a very
big area of astronomy now
so i think there probably would be some
exoplanets that we could target in in
the not too distant future
and you know just have a watch on them
looking for
stray radio signals or things like that
and avi wants us to go and explore i
mean is that is that at all feasible
could we even travel to these these
exoplanets
or just the distance is far too
yeah extreme
first of all we couldn't but we could we
send satellites could we send probes and
we could but you have to be very patient
um this exploration is in danger of
taking several lifetimes
and human memory is probably not good
enough to provide that kind of
continuity so
i i'm not convinced that we can go
explore i think we can listen i think
that's the main thing
[Music]
are we alone no
and i'll explain why
i think we live in an amazing universe
our planet itself is beautiful and
amazing the diversity of life we just
find on our planet is quite fantastic
quite awe-inspiring but let's go further
out of it let's look at our solar system
as a space scientist i've worked on a
number of probes we're going out there
we're trying to find life it is almost
like the holy grail and we found nothing
nothing in our solar system okay let's
go a bit further out let's look at our
galaxy our galaxy is the milky way our
sun is our local star and it is just
like the stars we see out there some are
bigger some are smaller but basically
the same so every star we see in the
night sky is a sun like our sun with
planets going around it so just in the
milky way 200 approximately 200 billion
stars if each one of those stars has
just two planets going around it how
many planets is that just in our galaxy
okay let's go even further out let's
take on the whole of the universe um the
hubble space soundscape um was
initially a sort of a little problematic
the optics which is my field was very
embarrassing i didn't touch it it wasn't
me but the optics were problematic but
when they fixed it we've been getting
some fantastic images back but one of
the things that the hubble space
telescope did is it did something really
odd and i met the chap who actually
commissioned this work it looked as a
piece of what we thought was empty space
for six whole days to get a really long
exposure and when we got the data back
we analyzed it and we realized that it
wasn't empty at all but there was points
of light out there and when we analyzed
the points of light we realized that
these points of light were actually
galaxies so from that tiny piece of
space we could scale up and try and work
out how many galaxies are in the
universe and we worked out that in the
universe there's approximately
100 billion galaxies our galaxy the
milky way 200 billion stars each one of
those starts with planets going around
it to a 100 billion galaxies in the
universe why would life just occur here
we must have every shape and variety of
planet out there again why would life
just occur here so i think there is
definitely life out there so why haven't
we found it well the problem is the
universe is ginormously big
um if we want to use current technology
so um the voyager space probe was
launched in the 1970s it's sort of done
some fantastic flybys of other planets
and it's just about reached the edge of
the solar system and this is really
exciting this is the first man-made
object a woman-made object i'm sure
there were women involved this is the
first object that weighed by people that
has reached the edge of the solar system
but it's taken 30 years to get there
now let's say that um voyager continues
on its journey and it heads out to
another star to get to the next next
door neighbor star proxima centauri now
the voyage is traveling at quite speed
it's trafficking at ten and a half miles
a second so it's going at a fair clip
but to get to the next door neighbor
star just in our galaxy is going to take
76
000 years so we're talking about huge
scales now even traveling at the speed
of light it will take four and a quarter
years to get to our next-door neighbor
star so things in our actually on the
time scale that we work on things are
quite big
now so um so i think there's life out
there i don't think we've found it
because if there is life out there and
there's something called the drake
equation which tries to predict the sort
of
occurrence of intelligent life in our
galaxy and it's based on all sorts of
things you know um star formation the
number of planets all sorts of things
also time scales if you think about it i
reckon some aliens probably came to
earth at the time of the dinosaurs and
said we don't like these guys we're off
so you've got to get everything working
in the same time frame so i think that
life's out there but the probability of
interacting with intelligent life is
just so slim
we have been sending messages through
seti and people like that out into space
and hoping that someone will pick it up
and i hope that there's other
intelligent life out there sending
messages and no we haven't detected each
other yet
but one of the interesting things is
that all the radio and tv signals we
send out here on earth lots of that
escapes into space so um they're
probably watching east enders on proxima
centauri but there's about four and a
half years or four and a quarter years
out of date so things are getting out
there but the if you think of it it's
like a ripple on a pond you drop a stone
the ripple gets weaker and weaker and
weaker so by the time our signals get
out there they're incredibly weak so i
really believe there's life out there
but i think the publicity of us finding
it or them finding us is slim so what
does that mean to us here on earth i
think that it means that we should be
considering um our position here on
earth my hope for the future is that
aliens do come they find us they come
and they say we're taking over the
planet they've got crossbars and things
like that but anyway
are they taking over the planet and we
say oh no and for the first time in our
history we all team together because we
see ourselves as the human race not
distant people different colours
different we see ourselves as the human
race and then when we band together the
aliens say oh don't worry i was only
teasing so that's my hope for the future
the aliens find us and it joins us and
unites us as a people
[Music]
about 95 of the universe we don't
understand
and we we use this term the dart
universe to describe
that part of the universe the other five
percent is the stuff that you and i are
made up of and the earth and the moon
and the sun and everything we can see
this other 95 we call it dark um
because it's mysterious and we don't
understand it and there are two entities
on the dark side there's something that
we call dark matter
that's about a quarter of the universe
and then something that we're going to
call dark energy which is about 75
percent of the universe
we don't understand either
but
it's very exciting because when you
don't understand something that big like
95 percent of the universe it means
you're missing something you're missing
a key piece of the puzzle and so that's
the fun and exciting bit is trying to
work out what it is we're missing why
don't we understand
what we can see out there in the
universe
and how has it first sort of discovered
that there's this sort of 95 percent
unaccounted for yeah so we're talking
about the two different parts so the
dark matter side of things uh that
happened back in the 1930s um a guy
called fritz vicki was looking at how
fast uh galaxies were moving around
um
so let's see i want you to imagine
embrace your inner cow girl and i want
you to imagine you're spinning something
around your head okay the faster you
spin something the tighter you have to
hold on to it yeah okay so he was
looking about how fast these galaxies
were moving around
and uh they were just moving too fast
for the gravity to hold them all
together so when you're spinning
something around your head it's the
string that's keeping it attached but
out in the universe when things are
moving around it's gravity that's
keeping things together so fritz vicki
said there must be additional stuff out
there that i can't see
he was german so he called it duncan
material which translates as dark matter
everyone thought he was completely
insane now then the fabulous vera rubin
an amazing astrophysicist she came along
and did some really really detailed
detailed experiments where she measured
the same effect in galaxies uh everyone
also thought she was mad but because her
experiments were so meticulous and so
perfect um it became really understood
that indeed around every galaxy there's
a massive clump of dark matter so that
was in the 70s 80s
so that was the first component of the
dark universe now let's move forward to
1998
where
people were looking at distant galaxies
now i've noticed the 1920s that the
universe is expanding so the further you
look away in the universe all these
galaxies are moving away from us
but in 1998 they realized that
the galaxies that were even further away
were moving away faster so not only is
our universe growing
but the rate of that growth is getting
faster and faster
and i think because fritz vicki back in
the 30s called
this
extra matter that was needed dark matter
we ended up calling this extra energy
that's needed to power this expansion
dark energy but i think it's really just
because we're all star wars nuts and we
like to say dark matter and dark energy
that's quite exploring
there you go that's the dark universe in
a nutshell
and where has your work taking you yeah
so i look at both of these entities um
so my uh thing that i'm probably most
well known of is for making maps of the
dark matter so it's completely invisible
you can't see it but you can tell that
it's there because of the effect that it
has on the things that we can see
and so einstein in his theory of general
relativity said that if you have a clump
of matter
um
it will curve the entirety of space-time
so uh imagine
you're the observer on earth with the
telescope looking up at me a distant
galaxy if a big clump of dark matter was
in between us
it would distort the way my face looked
and that's just because the whole of
space and time has been distorted and
that's the technique that i use to map
out where all the dark matter is
uh so that was sort of my early work and
now i've been using that to also tell me
about dark energy because dark matter
and dark energy kind of
one-up each other in the universe so
dark matter's trying to pull everything
together it's like the strong
gravitational force that pulls
everything together
and because dark energy is causing the
expansion of the universe to accelerate
it makes it ever harder for dark matter
to pull those structures together so by
mapping out where all the dark matter is
and how that changes and evolves with
time then i can tell you i can confront
various different theories about what
could be causing this dark energy so my
job is to collect the data extract as
much information as we can from it and
then confront all of these wonderfully
varied and wild different theories on
what could
make up this dark side of our universe
so you work from the data
rather than
very basic i am not a theory well
i don't think you can ever do the two
independently so my work is always
driven by what the theories
are predicting like
i don't think there's any point in
coming up with a theory that doesn't
have
something that you can predict that's
observable from it there's not really
much point in coming up with a theory if
you can never test it um so i look at
the the theories that people are coming
up with i think how can we actually test
this what data do we need to test this
um
and over my career we've worked with
various different telescopes different
instruments to build up the data that we
need to test these different theories um
and we're even going so far as testing
einstein's theory of general relativity
itself so this text this technique
relies on einstein's theory of general
relativity um so we can use this data to
actually test the theory of gravity
itself
[Music]
saying that the standard model is flawed
uh is
you know a little bit too harsh judgment
i would say because we know it works
perfectly fine
uh and indeed that's kind of the problem
um we we would be happy if it turned out
to be more obviously flawed
so to say but we do certainly
know that it has some shortcomings so
interestingly i seem to see different
shortcomings than you do
so
dark matter for example it may be a
particle maybe it's not a particle so
maybe it's not necessary to change the
standard model at all it might it may be
something with our understanding of
gravity um that's the problem the mu and
g minus two yeah is kind of intriguing
but i mean for one it hasn't reached
five sigma that's the one thing and the
other thing is
as you certainly know it's a hideously
complicated calculation it might very
well be that there's just some problem
with the prediction from the standard
model
and that it doesn't actually hint
um that we have to look for new physics
um but there are other problems with the
standard model um one is um what you
already mentioned um it doesn't contain
gravity so we know that
in some way we have to combine the
standard model with gravity because the
particles in the standard model do
gravitate we know it
but we don't really know how it works so
that's that's certainly a big
shortcoming so we need a theory which
which is called quantum gravity that no
one really has any idea what it looks
like and the other peculiar thing about
the standard model are the neutrinos
so the neutrinos particle physicists you
know who work on accelerators usually
don't talk about them much because
they're somewhat hard to detect
um but the neutrinos
are really really puzzling because from
all the other particles on the standard
model we have a left-handed and a
right-handed version from the particles
that have masses but from the neutrinos
we've only ever seen the left-handed
version
and that's a problem because we need
both the left and the height right
handed versions to give masses to those
particles and we know they have masses
how does this come about
we know for this reason that there's
something missing in the standard model
either they have to be right-handed
neutrinos which are just so heavy that
we haven't seen them or there's
something weird with the neutrinos and
they're just different to all the other
particles in a standard model and
there's actually another anomaly which
was not only a
introduction
in the allison d miniboon data
which
looks for neutrino oscillations that's a
signal for neutrino masses
and that signal cannot be explained with
the standard model and it's actually now
at six sigma last time i looked so
that's really really puzzling and
indicates to me very strongly that the
standard model um has to be completed
there are probably some particles that
are missing
but and here's the thing you don't
actually have to change the standard
model all that much to add a few more
particles you know you can continue
using the same mathematical framework
and i don't think it will really be a
big paradigm shift
i think
where the big paradigm shift is going to
come from
is another thing that particle
physicists like to forget is that the
standard model
deep down is based on a quantum field
theory which brings in quantum mechanics
and the entire measurement process
and how a measurement works in quantum
mechanics is something that physicists
never really understood and so that's
where i think the big paradigm shift is
going to come from
what's going on why we're not making
progress i think it's a combination of
two things um the one thing is i i guess
that's the obvious thing to say um the
easy things have been done
like a hundred years ago and as a
scientific discipline becomes more
mature it becomes more difficult to see
new things and so it just takes more
time
but i also think that physicists have
not been
as careful
in thinking about what they're doing as
they should have been so it's on the one
side there's a problem with theory
development um
after the completion of the standard
model in the 1970s forces were really
really convinced that symmetries are
great and you can use symmetries for
everything and this is why they
constructed a whole new bunch of
theories
based on symmetry principles grant
unified theory supersymmetry as the name
already says
and they looked for evidence for them
and didn't find it
and now i think
you know that they tried it was was all
well and fine but at some point they
should have learned the lesson because
they tried it it didn't work but they
never
learned it and so they just continue
doing the same thing over and over and
over again and build bigger and bigger
detectors and they keep not finding
something new
so i think there's a
self-reflection missing
and
so these two problems kind of play into
each other because we have the
um theoreticians not being careful
enough thinking about what might be the
next
prediction to look for
then we build experiments that don't
find anything and so we just you know
continue to
not make any progress
[Music]
we have made some absolutely stunning
experimental
discoveries in physics in just the last
20 years which is pretty impressive
because two decades isn't an extremely
long time in the world of physics so um
so two
really recent discoveries that come to
mind that i think are relevant for our
discussion are the discovery of
gravitational waves that uh that was
long awaited right and and can confirm
einstein's prediction from general
relativity and then of course there was
the discovery of the higgs boson so
which was a confirmation of one of the
core predictions of the standard model
which you refer to uh which is really um
in some sense
the theory underlying all of particle
physics um so both of these discoveries
were highly anticipated and eagerly
awaited so and and and they confirmed
foundational theoretical work so it
would be difficult to say i think that
the g minus two result from fermilab is
more significant so i would instead say
that um
that it may be one of the most
transformational results of the 21st
century and transformational because
unlike the two discoveries i just
pointed out
um
it's shedding light on physics that's
outside of our current uh theoretical
frameworks right and so that's what's
that's what's so compelling about it and
um so in particle physics we've been
living in in sort of this um state of
growing dissonance right we how can the
standard model of particle physics do
such a splendid job of predicting
something like the higgs in fact
predicting every single particle and
finding that it that that that's within
its framework um and also doing such um
precision uh predictions so for example
it can predict two parts per trillion
accurately predict to parts per trillion
via the um magnetic moment of the
electron right so so how can an
experiment you know a theory that is um
on such firm ground also be completely
agnostic about the things that we know
right that that there's more matter than
antimatter uh how could it have
absolutely no idea uh where dark matter
comes from so we're living in this state
of uh of
of tension and we've been living there
for uh you know decades now and um and
it's just and it's just growing and and
so i think um
this experiment results which will only
improve in precision because we only
release 10 percent of our existing data
and this result which is of course
partnership with theoretical predictions
and they will also improve their
precision so these these results will go
forward and and improve and precision um
i think what it's done is it's really
poked a hole in the darkness right
that's what it's done it's given us a
guiding light to where we can start to
go to resolve this tension and what's
exciting is once you see one pinhole
often other pinholes come up for example
there's this new result from lhcb
about the ratio of b decays to mu plus
mu minus and e plus e minus it's a 3.1
sigma deviation so it's not discovery
but it's something that's um that that
may be pushing us all in the same
direction and i can guarantee that the
community is right now working very hard
on following through on those leads as
we speak
[Music]
so when we find something strange with
respect to what we already know in
physics and in science more generally we
try to think of something new which
hopefully
will be able to
make the strange not strange anymore and
to explain it
so
in the story that i'm going to tell you
these roles the strange the old and the
new will be played by particular actors
so the strange will be information
and in fact
a whole set of other things which
appear to be problematic
in
the old conception of physics which i
will call the prevailing conception of
fundamental physics
and this is quite old actually because
it's been around since galileo's and
newton's times um and
it's the
idea that
every law of nature
is expressed in terms of predictions
about
the state of the physical system
and about what
will happen to it
given the dynamical laws and initial
conditions of the universe so for
instance we've got a comet and in
celestial mechanics we want to expect to
to explain and to predict where the
comet will go even
that we know where it started
but turns out that this approach can't
accommodate things like information and
other things that i will tell you
because information and those other
things are not about
only about the state of the system and
not only about what happens to a system
so the new which is going to solve the
problem is um constructive theory
and uh constructed theory is this
radically new way of looking at
fundamental physics
that i
will outline in this in this talk
okay so we're ready to so sitting
comfortably we can start the story um
but we actually uh need so the first
thing to understand is why is
information strange
and well we have a little bit of a hint
as to why it is strange um
it doesn't really look like any of the
normal entities that we see in physics
so it's not um
properly observable it's not like
velocity or position
um it looks like it is uh independent of
physical details of the systems that
contain it and yet can only exist when
it's physically instantiated in a in a
transistor on or off um in a flag
in dna etc
and there's one thing about it that it
can be copied from one system to another
without its property's choi information
being changed so now i'm talking to you
the information in my words is getting
copied into you know vibrating molecules
of air and then it's kind of reaching
you and then getting transformed into
electrical signals in your brain etc and
in all these processes the information
stays the same
um
but there's a deeper point about
information which is problematic and to
understand that we um
we've got to take a tour to ancient
greece actually
right so um this is a story in the story
so this is a myth uh there's an
interesting myth which is uh an ancient
greek um
myth and it was already about
information
uh so the story is that um
so theseus um who was the son of aegis
the king of athens went to crete in
order to defeat the minotaur who was
terrible monster threatening athens
and so before going his father
made him promise that if um
he'd be successful in defeating the
minotaur he would put
white sails on uh the ship on his way
back
and had he been uh nonstop had he died
and he would put on i mean the crew
would put on black sails so that was the
agreement
um then they you know
theseus uh went to crete uh defeated the
monitor he met ariadne
and then he forgot about the thing that
he promised his father
and and so
he left the black sails on and
unfortunately um aegis when he saw that
that
you know he saw that
his son had died and he
um he committed suicide he threw himself
in the water and he drowned in the sea
and that's by the way why it's called
agency
um
but never mind that so what we are
really interested in here is the ship
because the ship
is capable of instantiating information
it's a signal it's really a bit of
information and there's a physical
property of it which allows this to be
possible and that's key to understanding
how to incorporate information into
fundamental physics
right so the ship can carry information
because
it can be in one of two attributes
white or black or actually white
sale showing and black sale showing
and those two attributes
can be copied
onto other physical systems such as
aegis mine for instance or a piece of
paper or a flag and so on
now these two properties are physical
properties of that system
and they tell us i mean they tell us
something about what the laws of physics
are because in other universes
it needs to be the case that such
processes are permitted
and if you look at them they have a
particular feature they're not about the
state of the ship they're about what you
can do to the ship what the ship could
be and in fact they are what
you know philosophers would call
counterfactual properties they're not
about what happens to the ship
but they're about what can be made to
happen to it
and um
now
the preventing conception of fundamental
physics cannot handle such entities
because it can only make predictions
about
where the ship will go and what staff
you will have
but we actually need to do something
more
and
just like we can't tell the story
without referring to these properties
we can't
explain uh what is out there in reality
if we can't accommodate these properties
in a fundamental theory of physics
that's why we need to supplement the
prevailing conception
the old conception of physics with
something new and
possibly with constructed theories
[Music]
most of the issue is that we've been
really focused on
trying to understand what the definition
of life is that we're trying to solve
and i think that's a big part of the
problem that really hasn't entered into
considerations about these very
hypotheses they're not really they're
making statements about some aspects of
life but not encompassing in the way
that nick was saying of like the origin
and all of evolution of life
um and so when i think about this
problem i think at what level of
description is a theory of life going to
be um and what level of explanation are
we asking for um and just to give sort
of analogy because um my background's in
physics i think of sort of current
frameworks for thinking about life sort
of like at the epic cycle phase of
development of understanding gravity so
like several thousand years ago you know
we have predictive and descriptive
models that were adequate for the time
and adequate for the observations that
we could take and it took you know 1500
years for
physics to emerge as a discipline and
galileo and newton to actually unify
terrestrial and celestial motion and
realize that there was an underlying
explanation that we call gravity for
those motions and then einstein to
actually realize that the properties of
gravity um were derived from the
curvature of space-time and um you know
this from this very different phenomena
about the physics of light right so um
so i'm using this as an analogy for what
we need to do in
talking about life because i think the
magnitude of the problem is actually
much deeper in terms of our descriptions
of the physical world and how we
understand it than people give it credit
for and most of the time when i hear
discussions about origins of life
they're kind of in the epicycle phase
and we're not asking these deeper
questions about why is it our current
physics theories can't account for all
of the richness that we see in life and
they're not explanatory of what we see
in life it doesn't mean those theories
are wrong they're right in the domains
they were developed for but it might be
that we need new physical principles and
new laws of nature to actually describe
life and just as an example in reference
to the chicken and egg problem there is
a chicken and egg problem in physics
which is that in the time of newton when
he came up with the idea of physics that
that most of physics is built on now he
built physics thinking that there were
dynamical laws that existed outside of
the universe and outside of time and
they were immutable and that requires an
initial state for the universe that you
have to specify or any dynamical system
you want to study in biology that gets
really tangled because we have this kind
of effect in living systems where it
looks like the rules depend on the
systems that exist they depend on the
actual things that are there so um it's
a very different kind of system and in
some way you could think about the law
depending on the state um and so they're
actually not not separable um and this
is sort of one of the issues the chicken
and the egg
in physics we have laws and states in
biology they're actually the same thing
i specify my dynamics as a a living
system i can move about and i have you
know causal efficacy and things so um so
i think really the the underlying issue
is what kind of explanatory theory do we
need to account for life and how much of
our current understanding is going to be
reinvented by coming up with this theory
and really thinking about life as a real
phenomena that exists in the universe
and needs explanation
but the question i'm interested in is
not just explaining the origins of life
but explaining why we're sitting here on
zoom right now having this conversation
because they're part of the same lineage
of information from when information
first emerged at the original life and
has been propagating across space and
time on our planet since um and that's a
much different kind of framing of the
question
may i ask do you see a problem with
information in biology as we know
biology
i do i see a problem like i i just don't
think there's there's a way of
reconciling it yeah i don't i don't
think that it's wrong i just think it's
not explanatory like um so i i would
like to be able to derive it from a
theory that has some
more explanatory power and more
generalizability and just as an example
i think i think there is some you're
you're putting information in your
experiments with the boundary conditions
so let's say that you could quantify
that in some way and you could say i put
a certain set of constraints on my
experiment then you know how much
information you put in and how much
information you get out from the
experiment and that tells you something
about how much the physics is actually
doing or the chemistry is doing that you
are not putting in the system
but we don't think about designing
origins of like experiments that way we
don't think about us as intelligent
agents biological agents observers in
the universe manipulating the system and
we're trying to study it in the same
ways that we have studied physical
systems in the past that don't have
observers and where that doesn't matter
but in biology it certainly matters that
we are information processing systems
started trying to study the origin of
information processing systems and
putting information and selection into
those systems to study their origin
it really matters um
and to the one final point i was going
to make um i think i got through my list
um it's just that this also um you know
there was a note about solving the
historical origins of life and that's
certainly a really interesting and
important problem understanding
ourselves um but there is also other
tractable ways of thinking about the
origins of life as a general process and
this comes more from artificial life and
messy chemistry type approaches where
you're not so constrained about
understanding the conditions of life on
earth but you ask how is it that
non-living chemical systems can
transition to living systems and i think
interfacing between people that are
thinking that space and people are
thinking about early earth history is
really important for moving the field
forward
for more debates talks and interviews
subscribe today to the institute of art
and ideas at iai tv